اه هو نعم يعني الايرانيين وكلائها بشكل
عام هم انحازوا بشكل كامل
لصالح روسيا
ولكن مساله بدفع مقاتلين انا اعتقد انه لم
يحدث لانه ايران صراعتها الحقيقيه هي في
المنطقه والدول العربيه لكن هم تبنوا فكره
تاييد روسيا لكن ايران مدت روسيا يعني
يعني بالطيران مشير وفي بدايه الحرب كان
هناك حديث عن نقل بعض المقاتلين من سوريا
الى روسيا وايضا كان في احاديث كثيره عن
مساله ان يكون هناك يعني من وكلاء ايران
يذهبون للقتال في روسيا لكن عمليا هذا
الامر لم يتم بالشكل المطروح لاسباب
متعدده اولا مثلها مثل حتى المجال المجال
داخل المجال الحركات الارهابيه كالقاعده
السبب الرئيسي انه اولا روسيا هي في حاله
حرب مع الاسلام السياسي بشكل او باخر وهي
تخاف من تنميتها في مناطق رغم علاقتها رغم
علاقتها بايران لكن هي ضد فكره الاسلام
السياسي وادارت معارك طويله يعني عندها
وتخاف من
توظيفها في الصراع الا تحت مظله الدوله
الروسيه كما هو حاصل داخل الشيشه يعني
ورمضان
فقط هو تحت وايضا بعض القوه الاسلاميه بعض
المسلمين داخل الجيش الروسي وهم اقليات
لكن روسيا ايضا خايفه من مساله نمو
المعارضه من جديد وهي معارضه ضغط طابع
عنيف كما كان في الشيشان وفي القوقاز
والجمهوريات الاسلاميه وبالتالي هي لم
تراهن على هذه المساله المساله الاخرى هي
راهنت على مساله بعث الحاله القوميه
القوميه الروسيه والاعتماد عليها حتى
المقات صحيح انهم اعلنوا الجهات يعني
وصدرت فتوى من الشيشان وان ما يجب بعض
المفتين داخل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه انما
يجري هو جهاد في سبيل الله لحمايه تصالح
روسيا لكنه حمايه روسيا لكن هي لصالح فكره
الدوله نفس الكلام عند الغرب عندهم حذر
ايضا في مساله توظيف الاسلام السياسي حتى
لا يتحول الى اشكاليه لاحقا عندهم حذر لكن
حسب تتبع الاستاذ ماهر
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني رحب في بدايه
الحرب بكل مقاتل متطوع لديه حساسيه ما
اتجاه روسيا يعني فتح الباب يعني لم لم
يستوقفه موضوع انه هذا فتح باب للجهاديين
يعني هو صحيح في هناك جهادين موجودين لكن
اغلبهم اهم من المعارضين
اللي هم في الجمهوريات الاسلاميه في
الجوجاج او اذا اغلبهم وهم مثل كتيبه
الشيخ منصور وايضا بعض المسلمين في القرد
موجوده ويقاتلوا لكن فاعليتهم ليست بهذيك
القوه صحيح انه وجه
يعني
اوكرانيا وجه الدعوه عبر رئيسها للكل ان
ياتوا للقتال لكن يبدو لي انه الكثير من
الاطراف الاسلاميه بسبب استنزافها في
الحروب المتعدده
كمل الجمله بسبب استنزال استنزافها
وملاحقتها وعدم وجود حاضن وداعم اساسي لها
للذهاب الى الى كرواتيا وايضا تخوفات
الغرب وركنوا على اليمين المتطرف الموجود
في الغرب